and i want to uh work a little harder
because a lot of you know my things
is i'm lazy let's go unhelpful advice
stroke unhopeful advice with anthony
gesselbach
hi guys i'm 17 and i feel lost i've had
no social life and i watched the world
pass me by i've been stuck in a void
that i can't escape for four years
most of the time it feels like the
moment bobby was about to get hit by his
father's golf club
scared confused frustrated and tired the
void
i like to call is when you're on the
search for something to feel relief but
everywhere
you look you can never find it i've
tried everything but stay the same
i remain alone in a world and i don't
feel a part of it like a wolf who tries
to wear sheep's clothes
my question is have you guys been stuck
in a void and if so when
more importantly what did you have to
tell yourself to get out of it
we'll call this guy d you go first i go
first what's up go ahead
i think i think you're in a good
position
i truly do and that like the people who
think they have their [ __ ] figured out
at 17
do not have the happiest of lives it's
like there were people who got jobs
right out of college who had like a
career and i was so jealous because i
like
i struggled for years before i even got
into stand-up that now those people
still have those same jobs yeah and i
had like 10 years of misery in order to
get to this
where i live an enviable life that if
you have your [ __ ] figured out at 17
like you are wrong
so to feel like a wolf in sheep's
clothing or to feel like an imposter
like that is a good thing because then
you use your 20s to figure out what you
want to do and you have unlimited
options
but i think i would be afraid if i
thought i had things figured out or i
had a great social life like
you have work to do but you're you're a
17.
so you have plenty of time to do that
work and you you're not going to
romanticize
your your years in high school you're
going to like look for your
you're going to turn your life into
something great because you know what it
was like
you don't want to have the best years of
your life live be as
a teenager you want it to be later on
and like if you if the best years your
lives are in your 50s
that's a very successful life you know
even if your 30s and 40s are miserable
like
so just kind of embrace that you you get
you get to be
different you get to you get to be
not like everyone else and that's a gift
also like 17 i was very introspective in
that way like when i
graduated from high school i all i took
was philosophy classes and
in junior high and i would you know i
mean read sartre and kierkegaard and all
this stuff and just
and just that's when i would journal as
well and i was very introspective
and i was very um you know analyzing
myself within
and also on the outside was very
sensitive to the outside world
and i was you know it was also at a time
when people
like my friends would go to like club
med or
you know i mean spring break and these
white dudes would have
you know you know six packs and then be
on the beach with hot chicks
and you know doing tequila shot
meanwhile i'm like
you know working at coffee shops kind of
dumpy you know and like no [ __ ] at all
ever yeah i mean zero right
i had no like you know and but i'm so
happy all that stuff happened
because i got that [ __ ] later in life
you know i mean and i
went through a bunch of dark [ __ ] rehab
you know i mean and
you know being going to meetings at in
my 20s and
no money and and at if if i didn't have
those experiences
at 23 i walked by the comedy store
and it said open mic night on sundays it
was 1995. i went i just walked by
and with all i always thought about
doing it and
i looked at that sign and i went you
know what i'm gonna do it
and i just signed up and it went up but
without all that pain and suffering and
all that stuff i don't think i would
have done it
no and now you wouldn't have the
six-pack abs
yeah yeah how do you do can i get
six-packs
you definitely can yeah is it too late
just like with your stand up you're
getting in the way of yourself
you wouldn't want to do the work to get
a six-pack ab i wouldn't want to do the
work
because it's two-fold it's not even just
a working out you gotta eat well
yes yeah